now finally putting America first first
will invest in the American worker
we will breathe new life into your very
rundown highways railways and waterways
will transform our roads and bridges
from a source of endless frustration
into a source of absolutely incredible
pride
I've asked Republicans and Democrats in
Congress to come together and deliver
the biggest and boldest infrastructure
plan in the last half century the plan
generates an unprecedented 1.5 trillion
dollar investment in American
infrastructure well the president in
Ohio with this plan on infrastructure
kind of laying that out in a very
campaign style speech for President
Trump the bullet points here 200 billion
dollars in federal funding to spur as he
mentioned 1.5 trillion in infrastructure
investments kind of a public-private
partnership 100 billion for an
incentives program for additional
investments states localities private
sector 50 billion rebuilding rural
infrastructure 20 billion promoting
infrastructure projects 20 billion
expanding these the financing programs
10 billion dollars in capital revolving
fund to help reduce inefficient federal
property leasing what about this let's
bring in our panel Katie Pavlich news
editor at townhall.com
Susan page Washington bureau chief at
USA Today and bill McGurn mainstream
columnist for The Wall Street Journal
bill realistic um it's a little
realistic look the problem isn't can we
build this stuff there's two problems
who's gonna pay for it and can we get
permission to build it from the
regulatory process so those are the
areas I think where the president could
have a little more impact you know we
need a reform of how it's done in New
York and New Jersey for example so much
of this should have been done by the
local and state governments but because
of the the spending problems that they
have they don't have the money for it
yeah Susan well I think that there are
some citizens
a realistic prospect because it requires
them to come up with so much of the
money you know there's traditionally
been an 80/20 federal state to split
this puts us the other way around the
federal government putting about 20% of
the infrastructure spending now that
said I think there is a bipartisan
across the country consensus that we
need to have a bigger investment in
infrastructure but I'm not sure the
president's plan is one that is
politically feasible and I think the
prospects that it gets through Congress
this year are pretty slim yeah speaking
of process I mean we just went through
this omnibus and I just talked to
Governor Daniels about that it doesn't
seem like big legislative things are
going to happen prior to the midterms do
you agree with that Katie well according
to the White House senior official today
they're not looking for this to be a big
infrastructure plan in terms of it being
one big piece of legislation they
actually want to move this in parts they
want put certain committees on Capitol
Hill to take a look at the details and
push them through individually so I do
think that there is a chance that some
of these things can get passed in bites
and pieces rather than in a bigger piece
of legislation but I want to go back
quickly to the state's issue yes the
states are going to have to take on a
lot of the responsibility here but you
can also argue that because of that
there will be more accountability in
terms of the types of projects that they
do and that they have to take a look
that things they actually need rather
than going back to the stimulus type
package that we had with little
accountability and all of the federal
government money just getting dumped in
for the sake of doing project states are
gonna have to take a look at what they
actually need and make sure that the
money that they are putting on the table
and the money they're getting from the
federal government is well spent to
better their infrastructure in their
states
I mean clearly bill there is a process
that that is tough to go through if
you're trying to do any big project in
any state that that the the hoops that
you have to go through that's what
they're trying to affect yeah but back
to Katie's point I think it's a good
point you know if the federal government
is going to pick up most of the tab
there's not a lot of incentive for
states to be careful about the money
being spent you know in in New York of
course we have this with this issue with
the gate gateway project the new tunnel
and you know nine out of ten people who
would use that are people like me
local commuters and so I would think why
should someone in Mississippi have to
pay for that or have to pay for the bulk
of that so I think we need what would be
nice is a lot of reform that creates
incentives for states to focus on what
they really need and and start to pay
for it themselves Donald Trump the
president today had one company in his
sights he tweeted out I have stated my
concerns with Amazon long before the
election unlike others they pay little
or no taxes to state and local
governments use our postal system as
their delivery boy causing tremendous
loss to the US and are putting many
thousands of retailers out of business
Susan it seems like he has Amazon
perhaps in the site he does and there
may be a variety of reasons why he's
criticized Amazon before and linked that
Jeff Bezos who owns Amazon with the
Washington Post which he also owns and
that that some people think that as part
of his motivation for taking on on
Amazon it is true that Amazon has been
disruptive for a lot of small businesses
in communities and that's a fair
conversation to have it is not accurate
to say that Amazon does not collect
sales tax however since last April April
of 2017 so for the last year Amazon has
had a policy of collecting sales tax
wherever there are communities who are
sales taxed states where sales tax is
levied so that's a criticism that used
to be made against Amazon that I think
is now a little a little out-of-date
here's Steve Forbes asked about this
kind of focusing in on one company a big
company Amazon free markets will work in
bringing that company down just as it
does with any other company over time
I'm old enough to remember GM when that
was the big bad company IBM when that
was the big bad company I was gonna take
over the world Walmart was gonna take
over the world and I was struggling so
let the free markets play out Katie yeah
I understand the president's willingness
and urge to level the playing field
certainly but if he's going after Jeff
Bezos and Amazon for personal reasons
then it's certainly an abuse of power
look States have taken this on
themselves in terms of looking at the
way that Amazon does third-party sales
and
their own types of sales tax so I have
also believe that the free market will
come into play here the other thing too
is there is Supreme Court precedent for
this going back to the 1990s when
catalogs were selling goods from state
to state and sales tax was not being
paid in states that they were not
actually located in the Supreme Court
ruled in favor of the catalogues now
Amazon is a little bit different and the
Supreme Court will hear a case in April
dealing with the tech side of that but
we have seen that this is not just an
Amazon issue there's some legal
precedent here about the taxes and the
way that they work when your third
selling from a third party or from a
different state a lot of states and
cities are courting Amazon for a big big
building somewhere we'll see where that
goes a panel as always thank you